[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo le magazine des temps forts à
l'assemblée et au sénat avec à mes côtés
au rayonnement ceni bonjour enria
gentiva est notre invité cette semaine
et rachid tu es mal sénateur du
val-d'oise et vice président du groupe
socialiste au sénat bonjour bonjour et
cette semaine des questions d'actualiser
des questions d'actualité paralysé par
la démission à 2 gérard collomb mardi
devant l'insistance de gérard collomb
emmanuel macron a dû se résoudre à
accepter sa démission alors qu'il avait
refusé la veille obligeant et d'un
philippe à réagir à chaud devant les
parlementaires
l'assemblée nationale a poursuivi cette
semaine l'examen de la loi pacte voulu
pour transformer les entreprises afin de
relancer la croissance
parmi les nombreuses mesures de cette
loi l'assemblée a voté la privatisation
de la française des jeux et d'aéroports
de paris
au grand dam de l'opposition qui
accusent l'état de brader le patrimoine
national
y aura-t-il une commission d' enquête
parlementaire sur les abus sexuels
commis dans l'église en france c'est la
volonté de certains parlementaires suite
à un appel lancé dans l'hebdomadaire
témoignage chrétien est signée par de
nombreuses personnalités
objectif faire la lumière sur le passé
et éviter que ces abus se reproduise
faut-il supprimer la clause de
conscience spécifique l ivg c'est la
volonté de sénateurs socialistes qui ont
déposé une proposition de loi dans ce
sens il estime que cette clause qui
laisse un médecin la liberté de refuser
un avortement est une menace insidieuse
pour les droits des femmes
et on entame cette semaine par la
démission finalement accepté de gérard
collomb
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le drame s'est joué en deux temps et en
partie à l'assemblée et au sénat mardi
lors des questions au gouvernement le
premier ministre a dû répondre à
l'improviste
al'annonce d'une seconde demande de
démission du ministre de l'intérieur une
démission d'abord refusé par emmanuel
macron en début de semaine l'exécutif a
semblé pris de court par l'un de ses
plus fidèles soutiens écoutez c'était
mardi au sénat aux termes de l'article
21 de la constitution le premier
ministre dirige l'action du gouvernement
toute l'action du gouvernement et jamais
madame la sénatrice
je ne laisserai le début du commencement
d'une hésitation pointé sur ce sujet le
premier ministre dirige l'action du
gouvernement aux termes de l'article 8
il lui revient de proposer au président
de la république la nomination ou la fin
de fonction d'un certain nombre de
ministres de l'ensemble des membres du
gouvernement je prendrai mes
responsabilités et j'aurai l'occasion de
faire au président de la république
les propositions que les dispositions
constitutionnelles prévoit et réserve au
premier ministre je vous remercie à
tchité mal vous avez trouvé le premier
miss pris de court dans l'hémicycle
mardi est ce qu'il ya eu un flottement
au sein de l'exécutif
effectivement je crois que c'est une
première dans notre pays qu'un premier
ministe découvre dans l'hémicycle la
démission d'un ministre d'état
c'est de ça dont il s'agit puisque
monsieur collomb depuis plusieurs
semaines avait lancé un sos
il voulait sortir de ce qui est devenu
aujourd'hui le radeau de la méduse ce
gouvernement et donc qu'est-ce qui se
passe ce que le départ de gérard collomb
est éclairant bien sûr je pourrais vous
parler des 7 autres départs dont des
ministres d'état comme suit l'eau mais
quand même gérard collomb c'est un
indicateur
c'est le premier qui dit il faut suivre
et même un comparse qui va le gagner et
c'est le premier à partir
pourquoi parce qu'ils voient que les
résultats ne sont pas là que ce
ouvernement l'a fait la poche des
français pour leur prendre du pognon sur
de la question du pouvoir d'achat et ils
voient bien qu'ils aient un impact
électoral très mauvais ils préfèrent
fuir avant que ne soit trop tard
et preuve en est c'est qu'une fois
arrivé à lyon ils annoncent qu'ils aient
bien candidat aux municipales mais sans
l'étiquette la plus qu'en marche donc
celui qui le premier avait dit faut y
aller avec ma nana kron et le premier à
dire il faut s' partir de schémas de
macron la macro ni je crois que c'est
l'acte de décès de la macro ni avec ce
qui vient de se passer dans cette
affaire c'est gérard collomb a
finalement été le maître des horloges
comme l'avait été
nicolas hulot lors de son départ est ce
qu'il ya un problème d'autorité de la
part de manuel macron prem's et qu
humaines nacre on a confondu l'autorité
à l'autoritarisme
il a expliqué à la terre entière et
notamment français vous l'avez encore
introduit hier il est agacé par les
français il est agacé par les
contre-pouvoirs les parlementaires les
syndicats les associations il est agacé
par son propre gouvernement
emmanuel macron ne tient plus rien alors
il fait de beaux discours mais dans les
faits et même la crau nous avait indiqué
qu'il allait relancer l'économie
aujourd'hui tous les voyants sont au
minimum alors hanche il allait relancer
l'europe aurait bien qu'aujourd'hui
l'état de l'europe et personnes personne
en europe ne soutient ou on le dit banco
aux propositions des manuels macro et
son propre gouvernement
il ne lui tient plus nicolas lau qui va
dans une matinale annoncé qu'il part et
là gérard collomb et pour reprendre une
formule footballistique il y a un banc
de touche trop faible il n'a pas les
moyens de remplacer le miz de
l'intérieur
depuis plusieurs jours il n'y a pas un
seul parlementaire
un seul autre aux ministres qu'ils
puissent faire au ministre de
l'intérieur ça interroge donc moi mon
souci c'est pas ce qu'il a perdu les
horloges et c'est tout ça est un concept
d'âge est assez fumée la réalité c'est
que les la politique est désavoué par
les français et l'attitude d'emmanuel
kron est également contestée et condamné
par les franges a racheté malfrats blais
nous dira finalement cette démission css
un symptôme du problème macron est-ce
que c'est pas plutôt un problème collomb
est ce que c'est pas l'histoire d'un
homme
qui prend peur pour sa réélection et
finalement qui quittent le navire à qui
la responsabilité mais je le dis et
redis moi je jarre collomb c'est
l'indicateur de la fin de la macro ni
c'est l'acte de décès de la macro ni
triomphante
ce n'était pas une erreur de casting
parce que par exemple françois hollande
ne l'avait pas pris comme comme les
espagnols de casting puisque comment on
peut juger cela c'est celui qui a permis
notamment le rapprochement et bayrou
c'est celui qui a permis à emmanuel
macron d'accéder au pouvoir
et d'ailleurs et manu macron nous l'a
dit et redit dans les tribunes dans les
interviews je vive le problème c'est
aujourd'hui la macro ni vous avez à côté
de ça trois ministres qui souhaitent
sauter sur paris justement vous le dites
n'est pas le seul à afficher des
ambitions municipales est ce que les
autres ministres doivent suivre son
exemple et démissionner du site
est-ce que les autres miss doivent
d'abord être ministre c'est la question
qui est posée pourquoi les autres
ministres ne sont pas ministres et passe
la moitié voire plus de leur temps à
chercher où atterrit aux prochaines
municipales
c'est ça le problème donc ces ministres
ont quitté le gouvernement ou être à
leur tâche à plein temps et le maître
des horloges doit nous dire moi je
considère que appartement ils sont en
campagne électorale ils doivent quitter
le gouvernement est donc aujourd'hui il
y en a une à une kyrielle bon et soul
allemand est à bout de souffle et c'est
le radeau de la méduse donc encore une
fois emmanuel macron aujourd'hui est
contesté par sa politique et par son
attitude et que globalement le départ de
gérard collomb est l'acte de décès de la
macro ni triomphante dans l'actualité
parlementaire cette semaine l'assemblée
nationale a poursuivi l'examen de la loi
pacte
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et parmi les nombreuses mesures de cette
vaste loi le volet privatisations la
semblait nationale a voté la
privatisation de la française des jeux
et du groupe aéroports de paris
au grand dam de l'opposition qui dénonce
une atteinte au patrimoine national et
une logique économique
maïté frémont pour 39 contre fait
l'article 49 et donc adopté avec cet
article
les députés ont ouvert la voie à la
privatisation du groupe adp l'état était
jusqu'à lors tenus par la loi de
conserver la majorité des parts de
l'entreprise
il pourra désormais vendre au privé
l'intégralité de ses actifs en rangs
serrés
l'opposition a clairement dénoncé cette
opération
j'ai bien l'impression que vous n'êtes
plus gaulliste parce que quand on est
gaulliste
on fait en sorte que le patrimoine des
infrastructures restent gérées par
l'état
nous avons vraiment le sentiment d'une
braderie qui est ouverte deux fleurons
qui sont les bijoux commun de la nation
pour permettre cette vente une série de
dispositions a été adoptée cette future
privatisation prendra la forme d'une
concession pour 70 ans après quoi l'état
retrouvera la pleine propriété du
foncier et des infrastructures autre feu
vert des députés
la possibilité pour l'état de se
désengager dans angie ou encore
l'ouverture à la privatisation de la
française des jeux
l'état l'a détient aujourd'hui à 72% et
devra en garder au minimum 20%
un principe pas de taux de retour aux
joueurs excessifs qu'ils développeraient
l'addiction aux jeux
trois éléments pour garantir ce principe
l'autorité indépendante l'état
régulateur l'état présent capitale la
française des jeux
enfin troisième élément touche tab au
figuré dans les ordonnances cette
semaine les députés ont également adopté
des mesures pour encourager l'épargné
salariale en la répartissant mieux dans
les entreprises
le forfait social sur l'intéressement ou
la participation en fonction du nombre
de salariés dans l'entreprise a été
supprimé un amendement de la majorité
pour mieux redistribuer la part
ticipation a également été adopté l'idée
baissé le plafond du salaire prise en
compte dans le calcul de 160000 à 120000
euros pour une meilleure redistribution
entre salariés racheter mal sur les
privatisations bruno le maire a renvoyé
la balle au parti socialiste mercredi
lors des questions au gouvernement
disant qu'on n'avait jamais tant
privatisé que sous la gauche
alors pourquoi fustiger aujourd'hui ces
privatisations quelle est la différence
on voit que ce gouvernement là
n'arrivent même plus à expliquer sa
politique si ce n'est par des petites
phrases il faut dire deux choses d'abord
pourquoi il ya ces privatisations
il ya quelques mois ce gouvernement
avait choisi par ordonnance de casser
encore le code du travail en me disant à
l'époque ça allait relancer l'économie
patatras ce n'est pas le cas idem sur
les sf senard relance pas l'économie
donc ils cherchent autre chose dont la
loi patte sur la loi pacte il ya un
problème de fond c'est que comme le
gouvernement a donné et donnent chaque
année 10 milliards d'euros plus riches
via l' isf et d'autres dispositifs
et comme il a fait le choix de la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation pour
23 25 milliards d'euros
il n'a plus de moyens de mener des
politiques publiques donc il nous reste
deux options un faire les poches des
français
pas les plus riches je vous rassure tous
les autres et le fait de la csg des
retraités etc
il continue et l'autre chose c'est
devant des bijoux de famille donc là sur
airport de paris par exemple
c'est une entreprise qui chaque année
permettait de donner des dividendes à
l'état dont qui rapporte au budget
d'état
qui donc c'est un patrimoine des
français qui rapporte français est donc
là l'état pour essayer de combler un
trou liées à sa politique va vendre ses
bijoux de famille donc c'est one shot
cette année ou la prochaine il y aura
des mots et demain il y aura plus de
dividendes et donc c'est une erreur
économique majeure après il fait le
choix de parler de la gauche mais moi je
pourrais pas de la gauche qui a
nationalisé dans ce pays sous françois
mitterrand je pourrais vous parler de la
gauche qui a effectivement fait des
choix sous lionel jospin mais souligne
jose part il y avait de la croissance et
de l'emploi
donc le jour où ce gouvernement-là
arrivera
un de la croissance et de l'emploi je
peux vous assurer que je serai prêt à
entendre ses leçons dont quoi s'énerve
vous opposerez sur ces privatisations
est évident et j'allais continuer vous
faites bien de le dire nous sommes dans
un régime bicamérisme c'est le
bicamérisme et le sénat vous avez raison
pour l'instant je vois les titres
l'assemblée oui au sénat le groupe
socialiste dont je suis l'un des
vice-présidents va s'opposer
parce que des ressasser la stratégie
économique de la france monsieur macron
voit la france comme des français
grincheuse et des tableurs excel
nous nous voyons la france comme un pays
de l'émancipation et qu'il faut que
chacun trouve sa place par l'école par
le travail par d'autres activités
tout ça c'est ce que nous avons une
vision différente de celle de monsieur
macron et de monsieur le maire et
valérie rabault ma collègue président du
groupe socialiste au sénat a raison le
dire à l'assemblée pardon excusez moi
parce que c'est patrick kanner qui est
président au sénat un bon président et
donc vallée rabbo a raison le gaullisme
que nous vendait monsieur le maire
monsieur darmanin c'est fini alors ils
ont fait le choix d'être totalement
libéraux et de répondre aux dictats de
monsieur macron alors sur un autre volet
de la loi sur la participation
l'intéressement dans l'entreprise qui
concerne beaucoup de salariés le
gouvernement a fini par accepter un
partage plus équitable entre les hauts
et les bas revenus il y aura finalement
une forme de redistribution est ce que
ça c'est pas une mesure de gauche
oui mais encore une fois c'est toujours
pareil que ce gouvernement là il prend
d'abord beaucoup d'argent qui vous
redonne quelques miettes et vous dire
regardez je vous ai redonné c'est ce qui
fait sur le plan pour voter mais sur ce
que vous êtes en train d'évoquer sur la
question de la réparer la participation
d'abord c'est pas toutes les entreprises
donc ça touche pas tous les français
deuxièmement pourquoi dans ce cas là at
il fait des choix contre pouvoir d'achat
pourquoi at il fait le choix de faire un
déséquilibre aujourd'hui la taxation
travail capital se fait en faveur du
capital
c'est le choix qu'il a faits dont il
donne d'abord beaucoup aux entreprises
il reprend beaucoup aux français et puis
dia tendez bougez pas je vous donne un
petit pourboire pour seul le second père
je n'ai je pas une petite gauche ce
gouvernement là ne mène en rien une
politique de
second moment là avec emmanuel macron et
monsieur edouard philippe mène une
politique banalement de droite
banalement libéral il fait le choix
d'aider les plus riches en espérant
qu'un jour venu lorenzo c'était pourra
en bénéficier
allez on en vient à notre troisième
thème faut-il créer une commission d'
enquête parlementaire sur les cas de
pédophilie dans l'église
[Musique]
la question peut sembler surprenante
mais l'idée en a été lancé cette semaine
à l'assemblée et au sénat les
parlementaires ont répondu à un appel
lancé quelques jours plus tôt par
plusieurs personnalités et des victimes
un appel parrainé par l'hebdomadaire
témoignage chrétien les députés
socialistes ont été les premiers à s'en
saisir
explication clément perreault si
l'église catholique n'arrive pas à faire
toute la lumière sur les crimes
pédophiles commis en son sein les
députés et les sénateurs peuvent s'en
charger voilà le message car on voyait
mardi le groupe socialiste à l'assemblée
en proposant cette commission d' enquête
parlementaire
une commission d enquête ce n'est jamais
la même chose que un rôle de juge mais
c'est la possibilité de faire la lumière
sur une question qui préoccupe largement
les français et ensuite s'il ya matière
de saisir de saisir la justice
l'initiative est saluée par la gauche
mais laisse la droite sceptiques
on est dans quelque chose qui qui relève
essentiellement et à mon avis uniquement
de la justice
et je vois pas en quoi une commission
parlementaire alors après si le groupe
ps décide de le faire ils le font il ya
besoin de se pencher sur le sujet sans
avoir de hier sur ce qui peut se passer
réellement au sein au sein de l'église
catholique et que ça doit être
l'occasion cette commission de pouvoir
le faire
cette annonce répond à un appel lancé
une semaine plus tôt dans l'hebdomadaire
témoignage chrétien par plusieurs
personnalités de la société civile
l'église catholique est régi par l'état
de droit elle n'échappe pas plus que les
autres à la loi républicaine elle doit
le faire devant la justice mais aussi
devant la représentation nationale au
sein du groupe majoritaire à l'assemblée
certains députés voit cette commission
denquête d'un bon oeil
c'est le cas de jacques maire député des
hauts de seine est signataire du texte
il y aura un débat dans notre groupe et
c'est un débat qui sera mené avec je
dirais précaution parce que ce sont des
sujets sensibles
je ne veux pas du tout préjuger de ce
que peuvent être les positions des uns
et des autres parce que je les ai prises
à titre personnel mais je suis persuadé
que beaucoup de députés partagent ma
préoccupation dont l'église catholique
la pertinence de cette démarche fait
débat certaines voix comme l'archevêque
de paris monseigneur au petit faut
preuve d'ouverture estime que cette
commission ne serait pas une entorse à
la laïcité a chuté mal est ce le rôle
d'une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
que de se saisir d'un tel sujet oui
c'est aussi son rôle d'abord il faut
préciser que comme vous l'avez dit ce
sont des hommes et des femmes qui sont
dans l'église catholique qui en appelle
aux parlementaires
ce sont des hommes notamment victime
aussi qui en appelle aux parlementaires
il y a deux choses différentes il ya
fasse un sujet aussi grave il faut le
rappeler dans d'autres pays
il y à des enquêtes parlementaires mais
face à ces cas graves et habillement la
question de la justice et il est normal
il est même bon que les victimes
puissent saisir la justice
mais ce n'est pas ça il n'y a pas de
concurrence avec une commission denquête
ce que nous disent celles et ceux qui
ont signé cet appel c'est dire 'est-ce
que vous parlementaire vous avez la
possibilité de faire en sorte que
pas de juger mais de regarder comment
tout ça c'est organisé comment l'église
comment l'as tu es française tout ça
pendant des années a pu perdurer sans
qu'aucune décision d'ampleur soient
prises pour protéger les victimes d'hier
et potentiellement de demain
donc c'est un sujet très important il
faut pas nier avoir une lésion de judith
de judiciaire parce que c'est la justice
ni de politique politicienne mais qu'est
ce que ça a à voir avec le sens le champ
législatif commission denquête est censé
déboucher sur des propositions
législatives normalement non elle est
censée déboucher la question des
parlementaires il
ils s'interrogent ils agissent sur
l'ensemble de la société et là c'est
bien fait de société
donc il n'y a en aucun cas une
impossibilité et moi je souhaite que
cette commission denquête soit d'abord
rassemble les parlementaires et soit
apaisée il n'est pas là le fait de juger
et l'église catholique
partout et d'ailleurs je termine parce
que dans les signataires je tiens à
souligner quand même la présence de deux
sénatrices que vous connaissez engagé
sur ces questions là laurence rossignol
qui a beaucoup fait en tant que ministre
et en tant que sénateur sénatrice pardon
sur ces questions là et marie pierre de
la gontrie et donc oui il y à là
aujourd'hui des françaises et français
des hommes d'église des victimes des
parlementaires existe peut-être qu'il
faudrait s'arrêter et regarder comment
tout cela a pu se faire et se
poursuivent encore une fois ce n'est pas
la justice qui en attendant elle n'est
pas lancé cette commission denquête 1
puisque valérie rabault qui préside le
groupe socialiste l'a réclamé mais
refuse d'utiliser son droit de tirage
qui aurait permis dont celle approfondie
la procédure pour faire simple
richard ferrand cette semaine a fermé la
porte à la création de cette commission
denquête est-ce que du coup il y aura
une initiative des sénateurs socialistes
comme nous sommes dans l'émission
parlement hebdo au parlement il ya deux
chambres donc les premiers à avoir réagi
c'est bien je voulais dit notamment
laurence rossignol et marie pierre de la
gontrie donc les sénatrices et sénateurs
socialistes ont réagi cette semaine il
ya eu effectivement une rencontre entre
les allées les celles et ceux qui ont
lancé l'appel et notamment patrick
haddad autres prisons groupe en groupe
socialiste nous nous souhaitons quoi 1
nous avons demandé au président du sénat
gérard larcher d'avoir une commission d'
enquête
senna si vous a répondu j'ai un marché
il ya des discussions
si ce n'était pas le cas effectivement
le groupe socialiste au sénat aurait à
lancer une commission d'un cran une
commission denquête au nom de son droit
de tirage
oui et gérard larcher est moins ferme
etc richard ferrand qui lui a fermé ses
portes
vous avez bien noté qu'elle applique en
marche et il n'y a aucune discussion sur
rien il y en a dia pas d'amendements
possibles
il n'y a pas de lien même pas eu de
commission d'un cadenas là sauf au bout
de quatre jours pour faire comme le
temple solaire et se suicider au sénat
c'est une chambre où il ya une
discussion pour moi je ne désespère pas
de voir gérard larcher accepter cette
commission enquête qui ont encore une
fois demandé par des personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui qui se dans l'église
catholique
et vous avez vu que l'archevêque de
paris ne s'est pas opposée
donc ce n'est pas encore une fois une
attaque ni envers l'église catholique
nine atteinte à la laïcité autre sujet
racheter man puisque plus de 40 ans
après la loi veil se repose la question
de la clause de conscience des médecins
en matière d'imagés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette clause introduite dans la loi veil
laisse à un médecin la liberté de ne pas
pratiquer un avortement des sénateurs
socialistes emmenés par laurence
rossignol ancien ministre des droits des
femmes proposent de supprimer cette
clause jugée comme une menace insidieuse
pour les droits des femmes
cécile 6 ouf pour faire une ivg
on retire une vie pour aider une
patiente en grande difficulté il faut
donc être motivé pour le faire parce que
retirer une vis c'est contraire à notre
éthique en tenant ces propos le
président du syndicat des gynécologues a
créé la polémique
personnellement opposé l ivg il refuse
désormais de la pratiquer sur notre
antenne
il est allé plus loin 1 les médecins qui
seraient contraints parce que on
admettrait pas leur clause de conscience
ont un grand risque de maltraiter les
patientes qui à linverse ont besoin
d'être aidés ne pas contraindre les
médecins à pratiquer l'avortement
c'est la seule condition qu avait
négocié simone veil au moment de
l'écriture de sa loi en 1974
cette clause de conscience spécifique l
ivg
les sénateurs socialistes propose de la
faire sauter cette clause de conscience
elle n'a plus d'utilité d'abord parce
que il ya un article du code de
déontologie médicale qui donne
possibilité toujours un médecin de ne
pas pratiquer un acte donc il n'y a
aucune obligation légale
de toute façon est par ailleurs le fait
de la maintenir ça envoie un message
négatif ça singularise ni vg qui
poserait un problème particulier une
proposition à laquelle s'oppose la
secrétaire d'état mme marlène schiappa
qui craint plus de violence envers les
femmes
je pense que la réalité c'est que quand
il ya des médecins qui sont opposés à
l'avortement
il est préférable que ces médecins ne
pratique pas d'avortement pour qui pour
les femmes parce qu'il ya un rapport qui
met en exergue ce que lui ce qui a été
appelé des violences d'une écologique
je crois que c'est culpabilisant pour
une femme de s'entendre dire le coeur
bat le bébé bien accroché mais ce que
vous voulez pas regarder l'échographie
etc
la ministre de la santé agnès buzyn a
demandé à un état des lieux de l'usaj de
la clause de conscience
pour savoir s'il ya toujours assez de
médecins pour pratiquer les ivg
mais pas très bon de conscience date de
la loi veil pour vous il est temps de la
supprimer
oui les aimants d'abord il faut régler
le problème dans sa globalité en 1974
effectivement pour permettre l'adoption
de cette avancée pour les femmes est
globalement pour la société il a fallu
accepter cette clause nous sommes
maintenant plus de 45 ans après et donc
quel est l'état des lieux aujourd'hui il
y a des difficultés pour des femmes de
pouvoir pratiquer les ivg en france
c'est ça le problème qui les posent
aujourd'hui donc ça va des plannings de
la fnac familiaux l'information qu'il
faut renforcer il faut effectivement
permettre aux femmes de pouvoir avoir un
droit réel celui d'avoir un ivg une ivg
en espèces quand elles le souhaitent
moi ce que je trouve choquant c'est que
le président du syndicat donne une image
déplorable de sa profession parce que il
y aurait des médecins qui pourraient
maltraité des patientes et quand je vois
madame schiappa qui à chaque fois nous
fait des grands discours mais quand ce
concrètement il faut agir
elle se défausse elle vient encore une
fois de se défausser sur les jets donc
moi je suis pour le retrait de cette
cause là parce que comme l'a dit mon
collègue un jeu mier il y a une clause
ont déjà les dires général pour les
médecins donc sorte on lit vg de cette
stigmatisation et renforçons renforçons
ce droit là pour qu'il soit vraiment
réel pour les françaises et les français
dont propre et l'émission touche à sa
fin je vous propose une image pour finir
celle d'un adieu d'un adios celle de
manuel valls camif à 16 ans de vie
parlementaire cette semaine il a pris la
parole pour une dernière question
gouvernement l'assemblée lui a rendu
hommage à citer mme al nounou seriez
levés pour applaudir votre ancien
camarade socialiste ou est ce que vous
auriez brandi comme la france insoumise
l'a fait mardi une pancarte avec écrit
bon débarras
c'est le monde n'est pas la plus grande
marche ou les insoumis ce que ce que
vous montrez ce sont les socialistes qui
ont applaudi sans se lever
donc le respect élémentaire est
nécessaire et moi mais bon il faut être
respectueux et vis-à-vis de manuel valls
témoin quand j'ai adhéré au parti shas
liste il ya maintenant très longtemps le
patron du département s'appelait manuel
vals j'étais dans le val d'oise
ok donc je serai respectueux et si
j'avais été député il n'est pas venu
sénat jeu j'aurais applaudi tout
simplement et je condamne effectivement
les pancartes qu'ils ont été déployés
mais ce sera le mot de la fin merci
racheter man l'avoir avec nous assure le
maire merci thibault on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
semaine d'actualité parlementaire
[Musique]
paris